[Music]
you met uh president obama recently i
did i was like at the kennedy center
honors um we were at the ceremony and
then as we were walking out someone
popped out of like a secret door and
you're like do you want to meet them
and i was like
yes
didn't know who i was going to meet
maybe to my death
a lot of times and mostly in life if
someone pops out of a door and says do
you want to meet them
you say no
and then they just do this and you
slowly go to bed
no it was pretty incredible um so my
wife's british and she saw me change
into something she's never seen which
was this like uber patriot when you're
waiting in line to see president obama
all of a sudden you're like oh my god
yes
yes like
anything i will vote for it this is the
best country in the world and you're so
scared
and um he looks like he's nine feet tall
when you get up to meet him and my wife
went first and she was so nervous to
meet him that he said oh hey how you
doing oh my gosh i really love what you
do god i love all your movies and she
went
oh my god i so appreciate that i so
appreciate that
yeah and i said emily and she was like
wait
wait
and so i was like you're acting very
dumb and he goes can't forget about this
guy i love the office and i went
just started crying
so both of us have been blacklisted from
the white house
it is funny though uh but that's because
i went shh
sleep no but i uh i
i don't even think it has to do with
what what political party you vote for
when you're going to meet a president
yeah the air around you changes it
becomes really intense it's crazy you
met grover cleveland i met grover
cleveland
his sideburns are that long
you know how it is yes the year was
1898.
no i was actually with my my wife and
our two kids and we did a function in
washington and they said if you know
just doing this line you get to meet the
president
and the president wasn't in the room yet
and then all of a sudden we heard this
we just heard someone say they're here
in like 45 seconds
and at that point my son who's six years
old decided to have a complete meltdown
and he was just like i don't want to
meet him
pick it take it easy
and then i'm this i'm hearing that and
i'm hearing like 34
in 30 in 25 and he's like
[Applause]
just somebody's got to put that kid down
i know
i'm sorry but
that's what i was thinking like
take a shot take it take it take it take
it all of a sudden beckett goes down
you're like he asked for him he asked
for hi how are you but you know what's
crazy he did
the minute the president walked in he
like pulled it together and was like
hello mr president
and then you know a minute immediately
after the leaving the president he was
like
and now he's secretary of state he is
secretary of snacks for the united
states of america and god bless him
god bless him